Fridge for the milk,
and I'm gonna make some raw butter.
But this butter is the best butter of the year
because it's spring grass butter.
That means it's the best tasting and best looking butter
you're gonna get all year.
I'm gonna have to go for all this milk right now
just to make sure it's not sour.
This might be sour because it's been sitting
in my fridge forever,
but actually, I think it's good.
Really? See the cream caps on these?
The longer the milk sits,
the firmer the cream becomes on top.
And this creates a natural cream cap to the milk
and sealing the milk off to bacteria.
You can see all the cream separating from the milk.
So the heavier cream will come to the top
and the lighter cream and the milk will stay underneath.
The store bought milk that you buy from Walmart or whatever
is homogenized
so that the milk and cream is put under extreme pressure,
and it makes the fat molecules very. So something. I'm a scientist,
but, you know, it makes the cream stay mixed inside the milk.
Well, this is raw milk,
and it hasn't been under a marginization or pasteurization.
So this cream is gonna stay as nature intended.
It's gonna raise to the top of this
still very thick cream on top.
Let's scoop it out.
So another cream cap.
Now I'm gonna get this all cleaned up and get stood up
ready to turn I'm going to turn this milk into butter.
I'm gonna use a food processor because it's the most convenient,
cleanest and efficient way to do it.
Um, yes,
I could use a butter churn, but I'm just not going to. Um,
yes, I could use my Kitchenaid mixer.
Um, that just makes a mess.
I wanna wanna walk away from it and let it do its thing
while I do something else.
So I'm gonna clean all this up.
I'm actually gonna let.
This is the cream I collected,
so half a gallon and the quart right here,
I'm gonna let this sit at room temperature and get warm. Um,
cause that makes better butter faster.
Um, if it's at room temperature now skims the milk.
All this milk has different destinations.
Some of them know this about this hours and go out to the pigs,
chickens and dogs.
The dogs do like raw milk.
I do mix in with their food.
So this milk right here is gonna head into the refrigerator
for the kids to drink
and for cooking.
The milk here on one side is gonna be made into mozzarella,
and the milk here on the right is gonna go out to the apples.
Although cream is at completely room temperature,
still kind of cold,
but it will work.
I just got done making the mozzarella
and now we're gonna blend up this cream.
10 years old and it's still doing me good. So
let's go.
So The cream goes through several stages.
It goes to whipped cream,
and then it splits off into butter.
My blender is definitely overfilled.
Comes with strain out,
and I'm just left with pure,
raw spring Jersey butter.
Nothing better.
Can you please